we sent a fishing vessel out to land's
end
where they loaded five metric ton of
cannabis onto a fishing vessel
prior to that we went out fishing and we
fished loads of cod we froze the cod we
put all the cannabis in there put ice
over it and then put the fish on it
[Music]
i had a father who was a career criminal
we lived in the flats in stockwell i had
a wonderful mother and she was like sort
of the antidote of my father there was a
complete mixture of opposites both my
parents and sadly my dad just couldn't
cope with life in a normal way he was
quite an aggressive man he was a
beautiful man as well
but my mother was the sort of the anchor
of the family she was the love of the
family
he's a funny child at a
very early age there was some
some sort of sort of sex abuse on me a
very young age when i was about five by
the babysitter so that had an influence
on
a major influence on who i feel i was
you know it was uh
it was quite uncomfortable it was quite
frightening in the sense that
it was um you know my parents was in the
next room and they didn't realize what
was going on so there was a scream in my
heart for my mother like it was an
abandonment situation
but that was sort of one of the first
things that sort of obviously affected
me you know
my siblings were brilliant they were
both sort of uh grade a students i
wasn't i couldn't concentrate
um i didn't function well at school and
in a very young age i started stealing
and getting myself in trouble
so what kind of men did you see your dad
uh when you were growing up
my dad was on this pedestal um
he was very well known in in the uh
criminal fraternity in london
you know the likes of the great train
robbers the cray twins and all things
like that
and he tried to maintain a lie that he
wasn't who he was and he tried to
protect his family by putting us in good
schools he pretended he was an antique
dealer
but he was a big criminal in london so
there was always that confusion and i
saw him do a few things
i see an act of violence not once but
twice
against someone else and that sort of
frightened the life out of me one day i
went out into the garage and he was
making a set of number plates
and obviously it was for for whatever it
was it was for obviously a robbery or
something like that
and then i started to realize that um
when i used to go out with my dad
there'd be certain people that we would
meet uh and and maybe i might see them
in the newspapers and i started to
realize that people like freddie fullman
who was a notorious
gangster in london
and it's weird and then i just grew into
it and then when i went to work for my
dad when i was about 17
uh he had a commercial uh used to sell
commercial lorries and i just started to
see things then you know and then they
was involved with the uh pornographic
shops that's crazy that it
in london and so a very early age i used
to go out and help him to collect the
money it was it was organized crime for
from day you know from
when i started to realize what he was
um it was like i wasn't surprised but
crime became really apparent to me when
i was about 19. i started stealing
antique furniture
in in places like harley street and
and things like that which i got
arrested for if i was an antique dealer
but it was all stolen goods
and and then i went from there to sort
of buying and selling drugs so a very
early age of about 22 23
i was earning sort of
copious amounts of money in comparison
to my pals my friends
and i wasn't frightened of the
consequences of criminal activities i i
was there was something that wasn't
right in me i i was i was a i was
dysfunctional i still i was full of rage
so i was forever trying to fix myself
whether it be wine women song money
and the criminal sort of fraternity sort
of ticked that box because it was always
a high and a low there's a danger you
live on the edge and the addict loves
that you know
so that was sort of how i developed into
a criminal
i was in a car chase with a friend of
mine
and there was a suspicion that there was
drugs in the car
and he was being followed
and we was in battersea
and the police drove past they see part
of the number plate
um they radioed it in by all accounts
and it was the guy they wanted
so they set up as a police chase
so and it went on for about three or
four miles but this guy could drive i
mean he was unbelievable
police were everywhere helicopters
we wound up going around the back of
tutan in south london and there's a
mental home there
and there was all this
big wooden fence about 18 foot up in the
air there was cocaine in the car
and he tried to go through the fence and
we corrugated post doing about 60 miles
an hour and the car went up in the air
he went through the window screen his
nose came out
the steering wheel embedded in his chest
and i was in the back and i dislocated
my ankle and my knee
police arrived
we get taken to court container hospital
taking the call i'm in a wheelchair
i've got internal bleeding
he's broken both of his arms his nose is
out there but he's wanted badly i wasn't
unfortunate for me
i got you can go if you don't get bowed
you go to a place called judging
chambers and i went to judging chambers
and i got bowel
came out the prison got well got better
and absconded i went to live in spain
this was in the early 80s when it was an
extradition thing that they couldn't
bring it back into the uk i was living
down there friends with my father
and they
they sort of helped me you know get
along my little journey i was only a
young kid my father was um a canadian
smuggler
uh and he was a big cannabis smuggler
with his partner another sort of
well-known sort of uh villain a guy
called joe pal
and
they was involved with um all sorts of
things and so i was on the peripherals
of that
so what were the things you did together
with your father
well we started smuggling cannabis um
um early days my sort of father was
they was involved out with the americans
you know the sort of the the five
families out in the states
um and i'm not saying that they was
involved with what went on here but i
think there was an influence there so it
was high level crime yeah and so when
they started smuggling into the uk
i just sort of went along with it and
like i say i was on the peripherals of
it sort of earning a little bits and
pieces
and then when i really got involved as i
grew older
um we started smuggling you know in in
very large amounts we sent a fishing
vessel out to land's end
where they loaded five metric ton of
cannabis onto a fishing vessel prior to
that we went out fishing and we fished
loads of cod we froze the cod
those big yellow uh
plastic or metal wherever they are
they put the fish in them we put all the
cannabis in there put ice over it and
then put the fish on it and funny enough
they called my dad the godfather
when he got arrested but anyway so yeah
so we bought it in as we was unloading
it
there was about 60 offices there because
there was about 17 people there
and uh i think there was about 12 or
something like that armed officers so it
was a an armed unit there waiting for us
all these lights went on like that and
they started shouting our names out
there was night sights there was a
rifles and they got hold of me and they
slung me to the floor
and they asked me again this sort of
trauma kid that i had inside of me a
penny for your faults
and they expected me to respond in a
very bad way because i act quite
aggressively a minute ago and i had a
tear in my hand all i could think about
was my children
what was your sentence
i got
well originally we was we had a three
million pound fine i'll do six years
and 12 and a half years so at one time
it looked like i was doing 18 years
they dropped one charge of the two and a
half ton
and the charge in the end was i think
four and a half metric tons and i got 12
and a half years what was life in prison
like
um
you know what
we're creatures of habit
um and i think whatever environment
we're in we sort of
adapt and obtain
i don't know how it works to be quite
honest with you but life in prison
wasn't that bad you know it wasn't sort
of
it wasn't bad where he was frightened or
you know we knew everybody we had we was
known on the streets of london and sort
of around
the place and i think you ca it comes
with a little bit of an ego and a pride
of prestige thing because you're at the
particular time it was the largest
importation of cannabis into the country
and life in prison you know you get what
you need sometimes you have you you have
your own little ways of going through it
but being with me dad was odd
i was in a prison cell when we died for
two years that was odd and as much as he
was a
um a cannabis smuggler he'd never used
cannabis before in his life until we was
in the cell together that was quite odd
that was quite strange
and i started to really get to know him
and i could see
that what he had in his discomfort i had
too he was very similar
and and so
my mum come up on a visit on the very
first visit and she said
you know you're gonna see things about
your dad that you don't like and she was
right because i could see myself
and it was things about like i say
things i didn't like about myself i
could see any old man
but you know we stuck together
and um
and he didn't realize how broken i was
are there any worst experiences
you can think of that you had in prison
well the worst experiences was
first of all it's overwhelming when you
hear how long you're doing
for me it was my children it was my
lovely kids who i wasn't going to see
for a while
um
but there wasn't really any the only
thing in prison is that you lose
you know
your freedom
but but for me freedom wasn't on the
outside
i was in my own prison
so what was the turning point for you
turning point was um
i suppose there was a guy who'd spent 22
years in the nick he was a lifer
and i just had a big fat joint in the
cell
and i saw a stone
and uh he come up to my door
and he said mike well he said there's
only one person that you've got to get
on with in this prison
and i said who's that thinking it was
another inmate he said he's yourself
and he was a recovering alcoholic
and he was 20 years sober and i went
back in the cell and i just knew
that i didn't get with michael
and i smoked more joints and a little
bit of a panic attack and there was a
bible there and i picked this bible up
and i was just scrolling through it
and i found a scripture in there that
says the faith the size of a mustard
seed and just for a minute
i felt peaceful i don't know how it
didn't last long but i remembered it
when the people come round down from htb
in the chapel
it was very similar
and they prayed this prayer there was
lots of men in the room
and something happened
it wasn't mess hysteria it wasn't
religious
it i didn't see jesus i didn't have a
vision
i didn't
it was just something
that
touched that called which connected me
to my mother
i felt that was a connection spiritually
but the reason i grabbed it because it
touched my pain my trauma my heartache
and it didn't sort of heal it straight
away but it was like a little key to a
lot but maybe
this might be where i find
my way out
so what was life out of prison like
well
when you come out of prison
it's
you know in prison the only thing you've
got to do is turn your light on and off
or you have no responsibilities other
than to look after yourself
so when you come out of prison you have
the best intentions
but the the monkey on the shoulder the
devil and the shoulder i was on a beach
down in west witterings
and a mate of mine was there who i used
to use drugs with
a lovely boy he he didn't realize and i
look up and and and i see some white
powder
but on the end of his nose and i asked
him for a bit
and he said yeah come on he remembered
the old days bit of nostalgia so i
relapsed but in that relapse it was it
cost me dearly
i i had enough i i had an affair
i went back to my old way of thinking i
hated myself again i was ashamed of
myself i had no money i couldn't afford
an oyster card you know it was crazy but
in that i just faith to believe that
something greater than me was about to
turn me around and it's been hard it's
been a hard journey but in losing it
i really found myself again
i really found myself again and and i
got taken from hollywood the cricklewood
and there's nothing wrong with
cricketwood but
so i came from the top of this sort of
thing and i and i smashed to the floor
and everyone i owed money
you know friends of mine family everyone
tried to help me
but i believe it was my faith that done
it and that's why i accepted it but i
think my attitude to life the principle
of life today
is if i'm kind of myself i can be kind
to everyone in here
and and i'm enjoying i'm starting to
enjoy life
again and and
and it's thanks to what i believe in
that i'm on my way to my age
to enjoy the autumn of my life with my
family
if you ever have to flee an airport
don't run out of departures because
that's we're expecting
you to go go down to arrivals because a
lot of other people
coming in there it's always a floor
under under departures